Justine - Hey guys, how's it going?
I'm here with Jenna.
Today, we are putting my matte black mixer to work.
This is the first time that I'm using it.
This is a limited edition KitchenAid, beautiful Artisan craft. This is- Jenna -
Should we lock it?- Justine - number 212 out of 500.
There's only 500 of these, so, of course, the first thing that I'm going to making in this is slime.
Jenna - I don't remember ever using this as a baking ingredient.
And, also, you probably shouldn't try this at home.
,Justine - Especially not with a very expensive mixer.
Jenna - No, no, no. 'Cause we don't know what's going to happen.
Justine - I don't know, I don't know what's gonna happen. I don't really know what the recipe is;
they just said glue and laundry detergent, and that's the two things that I have.
Jenna - Alright, so what do we do first?
Justine - First, we dump in the glue.
Jenna - All of it?
Justine - Well, yeah, that's why I got all of the glue.
Jenna - I thought, maybe, like, it was, like, an emergency glue.
Justine - Eu, eugh!
Slime content is super popular on YouTube, and I found this out because of my dear friends, The Fine Brothers.
We did a "YouTubers React To Slime."
Jenna - How do you think you're going to react to this slime?
What if you break your mixer?
Justine - Don't do that! Why are you getting it all over the side?
This is supposed to be organized sliming.
Oh!
Jenna - That is a sound.
Justine - (laughing) That's a sound.
Jenna - Oh!
Justine - Eugh!
(Justine laughing)
Jenna - Well formed turd.
Justine - True.
Eugh! Eugh!
Ooh! Boy! Mm! Tummy ticklin'! Oh, geez!
Oh NO! NO!
Slime content. Oh no!
Man!- Jenna - Ok, well...
Justine - Everything is a mess.
Jenna - Why are using a bread hook, or a dough hook, or whatever it is?
Justine - That's a dough hook.
Jenna - Dough hook.
Justine - Uh, because I don't know.
Oh jeez, Louise!
Alright.
Oh, no, I had glue in my hand and I touched my hair!
All right, I don't know what the consistency of this is supposed to be.
So, I'm gonna start mixin' the glue.
Jenna - "I'm gonna start mixing the glue."
(Justine laughs)
I don't think I like this.
Justine - And this is a dough hook. We're making slime.
I'm gonna put this green in, so, that's why I wore this nice shirt today.
Jenna - I also packed a green shirt.
Justine - Glittery and gooey!
This isn't mixing the way that I had hoped.
Jenna - No.
Justine - Maybe I need more
detergent!
Jenna - What if it splashes in our eyes, and we go blind?
Justine - Do you think that there is something else that I'm supposed to put in here?
Maybe I speed it up?
(KitchenAid whizzing)
Whoa, slime, it's sliming!
Jenna - Well, we ran out of glue.
Justine - Maybe we add more detergent.
(KitchenAid whizzing)
Jenna - I don't know how I feel about this.
(KitchenAid whirring)
Justine - I don't know if I like this.
Jenna - You've slimed me.
(inaudible)
Why is it not green? Okay, so...
Justine - What's it feel like?
Jenna - It feels absolutely like a big clunk of mozzarella cheese.
Justine - Okay, well, that's, not sure if this actually worked out the way that it's supposed to.
Maybe we gotta get in there with our hands.
I followed nothing. Oh! Oh!
Wow, like,- Jenna - Is it slime?- Justine - this is incredible.
I hate it though.
I hate the touch, of the feeling.
Both - (singing) The touch, the feel of slime!
the fabric of our
Justine - lives.
Jenna - Oh, I don't like it.
(Justine gasps)
Justine - Ah! (gagging) (coughs) (gagging)
I don't like this feeling.
I don't want to touch it.
You can make it any color you want.
Jenna - Do you want to see how far it'll stretch?
Justine - No.
Jenna - (Justine laughing) This slime isn't to play with, it's just to look at.
(Both scream)
Justine - Why would you do that?
Jenna - I don't know!
Justine - You're an idiot.
Jenna - I wanted to hit it.
Now what do we do with the slime?
Justine - I don't know what to do with it.
This was not as fun as I thought.
Jenna - So, we definitely don't spike it.
Justine - Like, it feels disgusting.
I absolutely don't like this.
Jenna - You didn't want to stretch it. Here stretch.
Justine - Are we stretching the slime?
Is that what we're doing?
Jenna - So, what do we do? Do we cut the slime, with scissors?
Justine - Well no, so, the, in the Instagram videos, people, they just get, like, an overhead shot,
and then they, like, do this
They do that.
Jenna - I haven't seen one single slime video.
Justine - They call it satisfying slime.
Cool.
Well I feel like there's probably better recipes online, because this is not a recipe that I think that you should follow.
Basically, any recipe that I show you here is probably not something that you should ever try to do.
Jenna - Why does it look like that?
Justine - I think I might have put too much of, of the laundry detergent, maybe?
Jenna - My skin feels irritated.
Justine - I also feel like maybe I shouldn't have used Free and Gentle.
We need borax.
Jenna - We need blocked up and hard.
(Justine laughs)
Justine - (Jenna laughing) Well guys, thanks for watching.
If you have a better slime recipe, let me know, in the comments, below, I'm, I'm definitely not gonna make it;
I don't think I ever want to do this again.
Jenna - I'm sorry for slapping your slime. I just didn't know what else to do with it.
Justine - Slime slap!
Slap, slap, #slimeslap
Jenna - Can we get a slo-mo slap?
Just, like, wiggle it around.
(music)
The sound is even disgusting.
(Justine gags)
I hate it.
Justine - I'm gonna throw up.
(Jenna slaps the slime)
(Justine laughs)
(Jenna slaps the slime) (Both laugh)
Jenna - I don't think I like this.
(Justine drops slime in mixing bowl)
Justine - Alright, guys, thanks so much for watching.
This was not exactly as slimetastic that I, I'd hoped for.
Jenna - You stole my word.
Justine - I apologize to the slime community, of all of you slimers out there, that I have done you wrong.
This is not quite the recipe that I was hoping for.
Jenna - My bod-my skin is burning.
Justine - I don't like it.
This is not a good feeling, like it just, I'm sticky.
I'm sticky.
So, I'll see you guys
Jenna - I think I might have a rash.
later.
I hope you have a slimy day.
If you guys haven't seen the "YouTubers React" video, I'll also put that in the description. You guys can check that out, where we react to slime videos.
I don't like slime, at all.
This was a stupid idea.
Jenna - I think your slime is just, this is broken. This is broken slime.
Justine - Yeah, but, at least I put this really nice, beautiful, limited edition, matte black KitchenAid mixer to work.
Jenna - This is glue and laundry detergent.
Justine - That's stupid!
Jenna - And, now you're going to put something in this bowl that's gonna be edible?
Justine - Is anything that I put in this bowl ever edible in my kitchen?
Jenna - Never mind, It's probably safer just to eat this glue.
Don't eat the glue!
Justine - Don't eat the glue.
Okay, bye!
(music)